ja hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück
auf meinem kanal heute werden wir
tomaten sauce einkochen die sträucher
hängen ja voll
wir wissen schon gar nicht mehr wohin
mit den ganzen tomaten und dann das ist
natürlich toll
die hyper zu machen so dass man im
winter immer noch ein bisschen sommer
feeling hat dass man sich aus der
vorratskammer einfach in glas
tomatensoße holen kann aus dem eigenen
garten egal ob es draußen gerade schneit
und stürmt ich bin das ist immer super
tolles gefühl
man kann super schnell einfach etwas auf
den tisch zaubern aus dem eigenen garten
das ist so ein bisschen selbst gemachtes
fast food oder und die tomatensoße kann
man ja für alle möglichen sachen
verwenden nicht nur für nudeln mit
tomatensoße sondern zum beispiel auch
weil man immer sagen hier machen möchte
oder als tomatensoße auf der pizza und
so seiten und heute werde ich euch ein
super einfaches und leckeres rezept
zeigen
gerade wenn man sehr viel tomatensoße
verarbeiten will wie wir das jedes jahr
machen dann geht das ruckzuck mit diesem
rezept er zeige ich euch dann auch wie
ihr die tomatensoße so einfach dass die
sicherheit bei ist botulismus ist auch
bei tomaten sauce ein thema denn tomaten
haben ein ph-wert der ziemlich genau auf
dieser kritischen grenze liegt deswegen
solltet ihr der tomatensauce immer auch
zitronensaft hinzufügen und zwar in den
mengen wie ich sie im rezept zeige also
haltet euch da an diese menge angaben
die ich euch gleich an die hand geben
damit der ph wert auf jeden fall
unterlegt denn dann greift ihr keinen
druck ein kochkessel um eure tomatensoße
haltbar zu machen sondern kann das ganz
einfach in einem normalen kochtopf
machen oder in einem ein kochtopf zu
einem ganz normalen um ist das nicht
unter druck machen ich weiß viele von
euch haben so ein teil nicht
das braucht man für tomatensoße auch
nicht wenn man sich an diese
mengenangaben hält und da eben ein
bisschen zitronensaft hinzufügt damit
der klare ein bisschen abgesenkt wird
wenn ihr das thema botulismus jetzt noch
gar nichts sagt dann schau dir auf jeden
fall dieses video da oben an
das ist ganz ganz wichtig dass du dich
damit auseinandersetzt bevor du selber
ein kochs denn botulismus ist eine
mit der vergiftung die potenziell
tödlich ist da musst du dich jetzt nicht
von abschrecken lassen also es gibt
einfache möglichkeiten die man das
sicher verhindert und dieses rezept ist
sicher um die tomatensoße so haltbar zu
machen das soll niemand am ende über der
kloschüssel hängt oder sogar im
krankenhaus landet aber bevor du das
erste mal ein kochst oder selbst wenn du
schon mal eingekocht hast aber dich mit
botulismus noch nicht auseinandergesetzt
hast dann schau dir auf jeden fall das
video an das ist ganz ganz wichtig aber
jetzt fangen wir an mit unserer
tomatensoße und meinem tomatensoße
rezept viel spaß
du brauchst für dieses rezept drei kilo
tomaten eine große zwiebel 1 bis 4
knoblauchzehen je nachdem wie der
knoblauch magst ich nehme natürlich viel
frische kräuter aus dem garten zb
rosmarin thymian und oregano fünf
esslöffel agaven dicksaft fünf esslöffel
zitronensaft und ein bisschen öl zum
anbraten salz und pfeffer noch zum
abschmecken
du solltest natürlich beim einkochen
immer nur einwandfreies obst und gemüse
verwenden so war es zum beispiel würdig
aussortieren fange mit den zwiebeln an
die müssen nämlich unbedingt gut
angebraten sein weil sie sonst im
einkauf klaas kehren könnten also
schnapp dir einen großen topf und bradys
wiebel in dem öl durch dann kommt der
knoblauch dazu bis auch der gold
angebraten ist und die kräuter wir
kochen jeden sommer unmengen tomatensoße
ein deswegen haben wir im letzten jahr
hinter in trick ausgedacht der richtig
zeit spart wir schneiden nämlich die
tomaten nicht mehr klein sondern
halbieren sie nur entfernen den
stielansatz und geben sie so in den topf
das funktioniert wirklich gut probiert
es mal aus wenn du keine tomaten schein
in deiner tomatensoße haben willst dann
musst dir die tomaten natürlich erstmal
schauen was ziemlich viel arbeit macht
wenn ihr das wichtig ist dann macht das
wir mögen unsere tomatensoße auch mit
zahlen also sparen wir uns den schritt
ich gebe jetzt noch ein kleines bisschen
wasser dazu damit die tomaten nicht
anbrennen dann kannst du alle restlichen
zutaten dazugeben
also den zitronensaft im hafen dicksaft
oder honig salz und pfeffer nach
geschmack der zitronensaft ist bei
diesem rezept übrigens ganz besonders
wichtig weil er den ph-wert der soße
soweit
dass du sie nicht in bruck kessel
einkochen muss tomaten liegen vom
säuregrad her genau auf der grenze
zwischen wasserbad und druck einkochen
und der zitronensaft den du dazu gibst
der sorgt dafür dass du sie auf jeden
fall sicher im wasserbad ein kochen
kannst die tomaten hälften werden jetzt
ziemlich schnell durch kochen
dabei musste einfach immer wieder ein
bisschen umrühren bis alle tomaten
richtig durchgekocht sind konturiert du
das ganze ganz fein und lässt es unter
regelmäßigen gehören noch eine weile
kochen bis die sauce ein bisschen dicker
wird derzeit kannst du dann auch schon
mal gerne gläser vorbereiten egal ob du
schraubgläser verwendest oder einkocht
leser sie sollten auf jeden fall gut
gespielt sein abkochen musst du die
gläser nicht weil die einkaufszeit bei
diesem rezept 30 minuten beträgt und die
gläser dadurch ausreichend sterilisiert
werden
die deckel und einbruch ringe musst du
aber auf jeden fall in essig wasser
mindestens fünf minuten lang sprudelnd
kochen bevor du sie verwendest dann
fühlst du die heiße tomatensoße mit
hilfe von trichter und schöpfkelle in
die gläser ein weil schraubte sein
solltest du mindestens zwei zentimeter
platz zum rand lassen wenn du weckgläser
verwendest im reichenhall bis ein
zentimeter platz zum rand völlig aus
deckel drauf und bei weg lesern die
klammer nicht vergessen dann wandern die
gläser in den ein kochtopf den duschen
mit heißem wasser gefüllt hast beim
einkochen ist es ganz wichtig dass das
wasser im ein kochtopf die gleiche
temperatur hat wie der inhalt der gläser
die heiße tomatensoße also brauchen wir
heißes wasser im topf die gläser kannst
du im topf auch stapel in solange das
oberste glas zu mindestens zwei dritteln
mit wasser bedeckt ist ist das gar kein
problem bei mir fehlt noch ein bisschen
wasser also für dich den top soweit mit
heiß und was er auch dass es passt
außerdem gebe ich immer noch einen
kleinen schuss essig in den kochtopf
damit sich auf den außenseiten der gasag
eine kalkablagerungen bilden decke drauf
thermometer reihen und in
hat an stellen die tomatensoße wollen
wir 30 minuten lang bei 90 grad
einkochen
deswegen warten wir bis das thermometer
und 90 grad anzeigt und dann stellen wir
einen timer auf 30 minuten
von jetzt an zelten nämlich die ein
kochzeit wenn diese 30 minuten
abgelaufen sind dann kannst du deinen er
hat wieder abstellen und die gläser aus
dem topf entnehmen aber vorsicht wenn du
den decke anhebt und das auch dass du
dich nicht an dem heißen dampfer bremst
jetzt hebst du die gläser auf ein
geschirrtuch dafür sind diese glashäger
hier wirklich sehr praktisch und da
lässt du sie stehen bis sie komplett
abgekühlt sind danach kannst du die
klammern ab machen und die tomatensoße
ist fertig gekocht ich veranstalte
übrigens regelmäßig im sommer eine macht
eine ernte haltbar challenge mit allen
leuten die man newsletter eingetragen
sind wenn du schon länger mit dabei bist
dann kennst du das noch da werden wir
dann zusammen ein kochen und zementieren
sachen haltbar machen und uns
gegenseitig so ein bisschen pushen
unterstützen das ergibt es dieses jahr
auch da kannst du dich gerne für
anmelden das ist komplett kostenlos
ich packte den link unten in die video
beschreibung das ist immer eine ganz
tolle sache
gerade wenn das vielleicht noch neu für
dich ist das haltbarmachen oder wenn du
lust hast dich mit anderen auszutauschen
da fühl mich dort immer noch extra
videos die man nur bekommt wenn man
dafür angemeldet ist wir kommen da
dieses jahr zusammen 10 pflaum 110
tieren zusammen erstellt unsere
vorratskammer pläne und das macht immer
riesig viel spaß also freue ich mich
total wenn du damit dabei bist wie
gesagt melde dich gerne kostenlos an das
ist immer eine ganz tolle lustige sache
aber die summe ist fertig ich freue mich
total wenn ihr mal berichtet unten in
den kommentaren ob ihr vielleicht noch
andere variationen von tomatensoße
einkauft oder andere tolle rezepte hat
mit tomate sie haben ja hier auf dem
kanal auch schon tomaten zusammen
kommentiert auch ein super leckeres
rezept finde ich richtig toll schreibt
gerne mal unten in die kommentare wenn
ihr das auch mitgemacht habt das video
verlege ich euch da oben
ansonsten freue ich mich total wenn ihr
dem video einen daumen nach oben geht
das hilft dem kanal ungemein weiter und
hilft mir weiter dass wir noch mehr
leute erreichen hier mit dem youtube
kanal ich verlinke euch da drüben eine
tour durch unsere vorratskammer wenn
euch interessiert wie das denn so
aussieht wenn man ja als selbstversorger
seine sein jahresbedarf haltbar macht da
unten verlege ich euch noch das
botulismus video also auf jeden fall
anschauen wenn ihr selber ein kocht ich
wünsche euch eine ganz tolle woche wir
sehen uns nächsten samstag wieder bis
dahin tschüss